et notre invité politique ce matin il
s'installe je vous en prie monsieur
ministre bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin jean en
normandie évidemment ministre de
l'agriculture et de l'alimentation
et on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse quotidienne régionale
représenté par eric richard bonjour eric
bonjour henriot merci d'être venus
spécialement pour cet hymne perdu eric
journalistes à la nouvelle république du
centre ouest on va commencer avec
l'actualité et vous dossier actualité
chargée un julien normandie et bien sûr
il ya cette inquiétude autour des prix
alors on a beaucoup parlé de
l'inquiétude autour des prix de
l'énergie du gaz électricité du
carburant mais aussi d'inquiétudes
autour de l'envolée des prix des
matières premières la farine le beurre
le lait comment vous comptez aider les
français à y faire face est-ce que des
dispositifs vont être prévues par le
plan d'abord il ya une situation et vous
avez raison de dire qui est une
situation de reprise économique cette
reprise économique très intense un peu
partout à travers le monde enfin
singulièrement en france il faut le dire
on a une croissance parmi les plus
fortes si ce n'est la plus forte
d'europe et cette situation un concours
à cette fameuse inflation des prix face
à ça il ya plusieurs choses qu'il nous
faut faire il ya d'abord apporter des
soutiens conjoncturels
je pense à l'indemnité inflation décidée
par le premier ministre et qui est à mes
yeux extrêmement importante et dans la
simplicité de la mise en oeuvre et dans
le fait que elle touche un très grand
nombre de nos concitoyens
ensuite il ya des réponses plus
structurelle je pense dans l'alimentaire
et vous l'avais dit il ya un enjeu qui
est très important qui est de s'assurer
que les hausses de coûts
elle ne se fasse pas au bénéfice de
certains et au détriment d'autres je
m'explique aujourd'hui on sait bien que
dans les négociations commerciales
agricoles agroalimentaires qui amène au
prix une fine et qu'on paye dans nos
supermarchés en fait vous avez trois
entités d'abord l'agriculteur qui
produit ensuite l'industriel et enfin la
grande distribution et on sait que
jusqu'à présent il y avait très peu de
transparence dans ce qui se passait à
l'intérieur d'ailleurs on appelle ça la
boîte la boîte de négociations
veut tout dire il n'y avait pas assez
transparence à l'intérieur et donc on a
adopté voter d'ailleurs à l'unanimité
par les deux chambres et l'assemblée et
le sénat a adopté une nouvelle loi qui
s'appelle et galim de qui entre en
fonctionnement à l'aider la semaine
dernière elle est entrée en
fonctionnement et qui vise à donner plus
de transparence c'est très important
pour moi parce que ça permettra de
s'assurer que quels que soient les
effets de l'inflation on s'assure que ça
ne soit pas des hausses indûment perçues
par certains au détriment des autres et
donc vous voyez il faut pas que les
distributeurs fassent de la marge mais
je sais ce
que je veux dire c'est que quand vous
avez des augmentations de coûts il
importe que ça soit à chaque fois
justifié ça peut on le voit aujourd'hui
on sait bien que tout augmente en termes
de matières premières du bois en passant
par l'acier et en passant par un certain
nombre de matières premières mais ce qui
est très important c'est que dans ces
négociations
à chaque fois ça soit le juste prix et
la juste rémunération des uns et des
autres mais je sais que ça n'a pas
toujours été le cas donc il faut
apporter des mesures conjoncturelles de
soutien au pouvoir d'achat et des
mesures plus structurelles comme ce que
nous avons fait ce que ça veut dire
qu'il n'y aura pas pour aider les
français on a bien compris sur les
mesures structurelles conjoncturel mais
concrètement les gens qui demain vont
payer leurs baguettes plus cher parce
que c'est ce qui va arriver est ce qu'il
y aura une région où est ce que vous le
verrez que l'indemnité inflation de 100
euros
prend en compte l'augmentation
vous avez vu que le gouvernement a mis
en place un non pas une mais plusieurs
aides conjoncturelles d'abord sur le gaz
avec ce bouclier tarifaire ensuite sur
l'électricité pour limiter la hausse de
l'électricité qui sinon se seraient
envolés en termes de prix maintenant
avec cette indemnité inflation qui comme
l'a présenté le premier ministre
d'ailleurs n'est pas une indemnité
ciblé uniquement sur le pétrole mais une
intimité ciblées sur ces inflations
au moment où je vous parle il ya déjà
toutes ces aides qui ont été mises en
place ensuite on est un gouvernement qui
s'adapte j'insiste sur un dernier les
aides ne sont pas exclusives ou et que
les prix de la farine du beurre du lait
on est un gouvernement vous savez qui
est très pragmatique notre objectif
c'est d'aider les français quand ils en
ont besoin c'est ce que nous avons fait
qu'il qui sur le gaz qui sur
l'électricité qui sur cet effet
inflation du moment et puis j'insiste
sur un autre point qui moi me paraît
fondamental parce que quand on parle de
pouvoir d'achat souvent on parle tout de
suite cheikhou indemnisation ou support
conjoncturelle la vraie réponse à ce
pouvoir d'achat c'est quoi c'est
évidemment l'accès au travail c'est
évidemment la rémunération du travail et
moi je suis très fier d'appartenir
d'appartenir à un gouvernement qui a
réussi à faire en sorte que le taux de
chômage de chômage pardon diminue à 7,6
pour cent ça n'était plus vu depuis plus
de dix ans on a créé depuis 2010 est
entre 800 mille et un million d'emplois
la vraie réponse au pouvoir d'achat
c'est ça restera toujours l'accès au
travail et la bonne rémunération du
travail dans le détail de l'indemnité et
d'inflation que vous évoquiez ça
concerne combien de personnes dans le
secteur agricole et comment vont se
passer les choses pour les salariés donc
on imagine au mois de décembre pour les
exploitants un petit peu plus tard c'est
ça va être ça va passer par le
truchement de la aimé ça c'est ça qui
est cette mutuelle la mutualité sociale
agricole qui fait un boulot absolument
formidable je voudrais vraiment en
profiter de votre question pour saluer
le travail de ces agents de c est lui
aussi l'a aimé ça vous savez c'est un
acteur de proximité un acteur social
dont on parle pas suffisamment mais qui
est très important sur nos territoires
on vient d'ailleurs d'adopter la
nouvelle convention d'objectifs et de
gestion pour donner les moyens elle a
aimé ça de mettre en place cette
indemnité
inflation pour mettre en place aussi
quelque chose dont on a peu parlé mais
qui arrive dès le mois prochain qui est
la revalorisation des retraites et
petites retraites des actifs avec des
propositions de loi qui ont été adoptées
là aussi avec une très large unanimité
des parlementaires et qui va permettre
de revaloriser les retraites notamment
les retraites les plus petit du monde
agricole ans et que c'était un gros gros
enjeu une grosse attente aussi et c'est
chose faite et donc ça arrive pour les
retraites de novembre payer 2 décembre
mais ça c'est fait aussi par la msa donc
il faut leur donner des moyens c'est ce
que nous fassions
alors je peux pas vous dire si ce sera
décembre ou juste après mais c'est
évidemment le plus rapidement possible
et par le truchement n'a aimé ça alors
on a justement un beaucoup engagé céder
ces deux dernières années dans les
filières de qualité dans la filière bio
notamment on sait que le prix et le prix
pour le consommateur est au centre aussi
de ces de ces dispositifs et de ses
enjeux justement l'inflation risquent
pas de bouleverser un peu la donne et
pourquoi pas peut-être de décourager les
consommateurs vers ses produits plus
chers ç'a toujours été le cas qui est de
l'inflation pas de l'inflation il ya
toujours eu ce que moi je qualifie
parfois de cette cohabitation des
contraires c'est à dire que en tant que
citoyen on demande toujours plus c'est
bien légitime que ce soit de transition
écologique que soit de transition
nutritionnelle
bref on demande toujours plus de qualité
écologique nutritionnelle de deux
valeurs alimentaires et en parallèle le
même citoyen lorsqu'il devient
consommateurs ne fait pas toujours un
acte d'achat conforme à ses demandes la
réalité c'est que ça ne peut pas être
l'agriculteur qui finance lui même sur
son compte de résultats l'ensemble de
ces transitions dix autres mentions
demande à nos agriculteurs de produire
avec une meilleure qualité cette qualité
elle doit être justement rémunérés
alors une fois que j'ai dit ça ça veut
dire que toutes celles et ceux qui en
ont les moyens que leur acte de
consommation soit conforme à leurs
demandes citoyennes c'est très important
ce n'est pas toujours le cas je crois
qu'on a tous conscience premier point
deuxième point il faut aider celles et
ceux qui le souhaiteraient à pouvoir
avoir c'est produire de quel produit de
qualité et qui n'ont pas la capacité
financière ça on voit la première
question dont on nous avons débattu et
enfin troisième point il faut que l'état
accompagne des agriculteurs dans
l'investissement pour plus facilement
produire et continuer à monter en
qualité et c'est ce que nous faisons
massivement à la fois avec france
relance à la fois avec france 2030
songez que france relance c'était un
milliard deux france 2030 c'est plus de
2 milliards que nous investissons dans
ses modèles agricoles et c'est aussi ce
que nous faisons à travers la politique
agricole commune on va parler des
responsabilités doivent être par qu'on
va parler tous ces sujets de france
relancer et de la pac mais juste une
dernière question sur les prix parce
qu'à aussi le prix des engrais azotés
qui augmentent et qui flambe même et en
même temps que le gaz qui sert à leur
fabrication forcément et ça provoque de
l'inquiétude chez les agriculteurs qui
se demandent si nous aurons les moyens
de fertiliser leurs chants qu'est ce que
vous leur répondez alors on est en lien
très étroit avec le monde agricole sur
ce sujet il ya 2 2 points il ya le sujet
prix tout en sachant que le prix tout
est corrélé que soient les engrais ou
que ce soit la vente à la fin par
exemple des céréales qui sont produits
mais au delà même de la question du prix
qui est un sujet très important et qu'on
suit avec beaucoup beaucoup d'attention
avec les professionnels et un deuxième
sujet c'est l'axé si l'accessibilité à
ces engrais alors en france on a de la
chance c'est qu'on est un pays qui est
producteur d'engrais ça nécessite aussi
pouvoir importer un certain nombre de
matières premières pour les produire
mais enfin on a des usines de production
d'engrais donc on suit avec la filière
de très près la situation pour être sûrs
que nous ayons la capacité d'avoir accès
ces engrais parce que quand on parle de
culture une culture l'engrais c'est la
nourriture des plantes donc c'est
absolument essentiel sur la france on a
cette capacité on a entre nîmes et sète
souveraineté mais il faut y faire très
attention c'est ce sur quoi nous nous
sommes en train de travailler avec
l'ensemble des professionnels pour être
sûr que les ancrer ce soit accessible à
nos agriculteurs et c'est ça ma priorité
la question après je me permets juste
après ce sujet des engrais il dépasse
largement la france et moi c'est un
débat que je porte au niveau européen et
au niveau international
parce que quand bien même on arrive à
assurer la souveraineté française pour
les engrais qui vous l'aurez compris est
ma priorité ça renvoie au débat de
l'accès à ces engrais à l'échelle
internationale et si demain vous avez
des pays qui n'ont pas accès à ces
anglais ça fait des chutes drastiques de
production et ça peut avoir des
conséquences dramatiques à l'échelle
internationale sur l'accès à
l'alimentation donc c'est un sujet que
je considère prioritaire sur lequel nous
travaillons beaucoup à l'échelle
nationale mais aussi à l'échelle est
justement une dernière question là
dessus sur l'échelle européenne
notamment puisque la confédération
européenne des producteurs de maïs
demandent à la commission de suspendre
des tarifs douaniers qui frappent les
importations de solutions azotées depuis
2010 ne vous soutenez ça demain on a
porté avec certains de mes collègues ce
sujet au niveau européen quelles que
soient les solutions techniques là il ya
une solution que vous évoquez il ya
peut-être d'autres solutions mais on a
porté lors du dernier conseil des
ministres qui a eu lieu il ya dix jours
ce sujet à la table du conseil europe 1
en disant attention on a là un vrai
sujet de souveraineté française vous
l'aurez compris moi je suis très
impliqué avec mes équipes et des
professionnels pour assurer notre
souveraineté mais aussi européennes mais
aussi international je pense par exemple
que la haye fao qui est l'organe
onusienne si je puis dire sur la
question alimentaire doit aussi se
saisir de ce sujet des engrais parce que
une pénurie d'engrais à l'échelle
mondiale a des conséquences alimentaires
absolument dramatique et donc c'est un
sujet je leur dis absolument prioritaire
à mes yeux à l'échelle nationale d'abord
mais aussi à l'échelle internationale et
on va parler de france relance osent en
parler avec à la question avec alors on
est aujourd'hui je crois 2 milliards 800
millions fléchés vers ce ce plan vous
aviez évoqué une une révolution agricole
une nouvelle révolution la troisième en
quelque sorte on a aussi beaucoup parlé
durant la crise bien au delà de la
reconquête de l'indépendance alimentaire
de la souveraineté sondés sont des
sujets sensibles est-ce que c'est
toujours je dirais autant d'actualité
autant l'objectif complètement voyons
viens de parler des engrais sur les
engrais moi ma priorité c'est notre
souveraineté alors on a de la chance
d'avoir un tissu industriel
on sait aussi qu'on a un défi c'est
comment on arrive demain à créer plus
d'engrais qui émettent moins de gaz à
effet de serre par exemple et donc on a
une capacité d'innovation pour être
s'ouvre dans la filière engrais mais en
plus souverain dans une filière engrais
qui
puisse faire une innovation tels que
l'impact sur les émissions de gaz à
effet serre soit soient réduits et donc
être à la pointe sur ce sujet on va
investir dans france 2030 sur ces
nouvelles filières d'engrais par exemple
c'est un élément très concret deuxième
exemple tout aussi concret on sait
aujourd'hui qu'on a ou priorité c'est de
reconquérir notre souveraineté dans les
protéines ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que ça et dans nos élevages par exemple
beaucoup de l'alimentation de nos
élevages constituent en fait par exemple
du soja importé il vient d'où il vient
d'amérique du sud et il est fait avec
des méthodes de production qui perd fois
concourra de la déforestation ou à de la
dégradation de la biodiversité et ça
fait cinquante ans que on a laissé filer
la chose ça fait cinquante ans qu'il ya
eu un système organisé vraiment à
l'échelle internationale houle en gros
le continent américain dit aux européens
faites votre politique agricole commune
à une condition vous restiez dépendants
de nos protéines et on a laissé la chose
s'installer jusqu'à il ya quelques
années pendant ce quinquennat où on a
lancé avec les professionnels un grand
plan protéines on investit plus de 120
millions d'euros pour reconquérir notre
souveraineté protéines concrètement
remettre des cultures de soja remettre
des cultures de légumineuses et ça
marche très bien on a aujourd'hui plus
de 50 projets de filières qui ont d'ores
et déjà été déposées et qu'on finance
alors ça prendra un temps certain mais
c'est une détermination totale de ma
part il n'y a pas de pays forçant
agriculture forte il n'y a pas de pays
souverain sans agriculture souveraine et
donc il faut investir massivement dans
cette souveraineté justement dans ce
plan de relance qu'il ya aussi un autre
en 2030 voilà voilà il ya aussi un axe
majeur c'est la profession elle-même ce
sont les professionnels à l'on sait que
l'agriculture est une profession
vieillissante la moitié à peu près de
l'effectif actuellement au travail ne le
sera plus d'ici une dizaine d'années
je dirais qu est ce qu on dit aux
entrants à ceux qui parlent parce qu'on
sait que malgré tout de plus en plus
c'est difficile que les parents que les
enfants
succède
qu'est ce qu'on dit aux jeunes qui sont
susceptibles de rejoindre la profession
il le faudra bien d'abord être
agriculteur vous travaillez dans
l'agroalimentaire c'est d'abord un
métier de passion cette passion vous
connaissez très bien nos territoires
vous la voyez tous les jours c'est un
métier de passion mais la passion elle
ne peut pas tout et la passion à ne peut
jamais se substituer à la rémunération
est donc quand vous êtes un jeune et que
vous voulez vous installez la question
vous vous posez c'est j'ai besoin
d'avoir la juste rémunération pour être
père mère de famille pour pouvoir élever
mes enfants et vivre convenablement et
donc au delà de la passion le deuxième
sujet c'est la rémunération et ça
renvoie ce que je disais tout à l'heure
par exemple sur la loi et game 2 elle
est essentielle cette fois il faut
assurer la juste rémunération de nos
agriculteurs elle est d'autant plus
essentielle que si vous n'avez pas une
rémunération vous pouvez pas investir
dans les transitions dans la qualité et
c est le troisième élément au delà de la
rémunération c'est que moi je pense
qu'il faut aussi se prémunir face à un
risque qui est un risque très présent
pour nos agriculteurs aujourd'hui qu'il
au risque du changement climatique
prenons un jeune qui s'installe quand
vous installez vous investissez parfois
plusieurs centaines de milliers d'euros
si les deux trois quatre cinq années
après votre installation vous prenez une
sécheresse mais on va parler d'elle eh
bien vous ne pouvez pas vous installez
sereinement et ça c'est la grande
réforme de l'assurance récolte qu'on est
en train de porter et qui est
essentielle mais essentiel à mes yeux
notamment pour l'installation des jeunes
et justement emmanuel macron il a promis
600 millions d'euros justement par an
pour indemniser les agriculteurs
victimes de catastrophes climatiques
cette promesse est ce qu elle s'est
traduite concrètement comment elle va se
traduire concret alors elle va se
traduire concrètement par un projet de
loi que je présenterai en conseil des
ministres le 1er décembre qui sera
débattu à l'assemblée nationale mi
janvier et probablement au sénat
quelques jours ou quelques semaines
juste après ce projet de loi c'est quoi
c'est la refonte de ce système de
protection et de couverture des risques
c'est à dire de rendre
accessible la possibilité aux
agriculteurs d'avoir un système qui nous
couvre des risques quand vous avez par
exemple le gel terrible qu'on a subie il
ya quelques mois ou ces événements de
sécheresses à répétition et donc on aura
ce projet de loi qui sera adopté je
l'espère
janvier-février en font sa compère
parlementaire voilà en tout cas avant la
fin la coupure parlementaire ensuite ce
projet de loi il y donne des fondations
de ce nouveau dispositif ensuite on aura
plusieurs mois pour détailler parce que
c'est des réformes incroyablement
technique pour détailler tous les
paramètres et puis ensuite cette réforme
n'entrera en application conformément à
ce qu'annonçait président la république
au 1er janvier 2023 c'est à dire au
moment où rentrent en vigueur la
nouvelle politique agricole commune donc
le système il doit être mise en place au
1er janvier 2023 et d'ailleurs la
traduction budgétaire indiqué par le
président de la république se retrouvera
donc dans le projet de loi de finances
fin 2022 pour 2005 à canal assure envie
de quel que soit le futur président
oui parce que les agriculteurs verrons
je vous en remercie de votre question
parce que en fait ce projet de loi que
je présente dans les tout prochains
jours il rend
créer un point de non retour il créé ce
nouveau dispositif est donc ce nouveau
dispositif
quoi qu'il advienne dans les prochains
mois ce sera forcément lui qui sera mise
en place en 2023 et c'est ça qui est à
mes yeux est extrêmement importante et
pas plus tard qu'hier soir en réunion
avec l'ensemble des acteurs pour
justement finaliser la rédaction de ce
projet loin et je le dis avec beaucoup
d'humilité mais mais mais vraiment
beaucoup de conviction je pense que
jour où on aura finalisé cette réforme
assurantielle de protection des risques
ce sera probablement la réforme la plus
structurante pour le monde agricole
depuis la mise en place de la politique
agricole commune est justement une
question sur cette politique agricole
commune puisque l'autorité
environnementale estime que la
déclinaison française delà de la pac
pour 2023 2027 ne prend pas suffisamment
en compte le juste niveau des enjeux
environnementaux est ce que vous allez
revoir votre copine elle aurait dit pas
exactement ça on pourrait en parler des
heures
elle interroge les ambitions
environnementales
c'est évidemment son rôle je le regarde
avec beaucoup de sérieux et d'ailleurs
cet avis est rendu public on va faire
même une consultation du public sur cet
avis donc on fait ces travaux en toute
transparence
moi j'attire juste attention collégiale
sur un point a notamment tous toutes
celles et ceux qui disent que la
politique agricole commune
n'accompagnerait pas suffisamment la
transition agro écologiques
cette nouvelle politique agricole
commune elle va très loin et d'ailleurs
la commission européenne elle-même à un
organe d'études cet organe d'études a
établi que du fait de l'ambition de
cette politique agricole commune et des
transitions la production au niveau
européen allait diminuer de 12 à 13%
que les prix allaient augmenter et quand
même moment parce qu'il ya certains
passent à des moments donnés les
importations allait augmenter
significativement et donc moi je dis si
quelles que soient nos ambitions si on
veut aller encore plus vite dans ces
transitions et si on veut aller plus
loin dans cette transition aujourd'hui
il faut absolument revoir un point non
pas la politique agricole commune mais
nos politiques commerciales pourquoi
parce que aujourd'hui sinon on fait nos
transitions mais si au même moment on
continue à importer aussi facilement des
produits qu'ils n'auraient pas
l'autorisation d'être produit chez nous
pas l'autorisation quel est le sens de
cela à la fois pour accompagner nos
agriculteurs dans cette transition c'est
leur produit est en compétition avec
d'autres quel est le sens même
environnementale quand vous importez un
produit que vous n'auriez pas autorisé
l'impact environnement elle est très
fort et quel est l'enjeu de souverainté
donc moi ma priorité aujourd'hui c'est
de faire avancer le sujet au niveau de
la politique commerciale et ce serait
une priorité de la présidence française
du conseil qui commence en janvier le
temps file jean en normandie on a encore
quelques questions d'abord sur la grippe
aviaire même si je sais que vous aimez
pas qu'on l'appelle comme ça mais est-ce
bien le servir est-ce qu'ils ont encore
des foyers que les paviens aujourd'hui
alors on est on est sortie de l'épisode
de très intense de l'année dernière et
au moment où je vous parle il ya quatre
foyers qui ont été détectés sur le sol
métropolitain mais des foyers dans des
basses-cours pas des foyers dans des
élevages donc dans quelques jours ou
dans des ou dans des des flux
migratoires des oiseaux sauvages et donc
aujourd'hui on a toujours le statut
indemme degré de différentes salles
aviaire mais on est passé du risque
faible à ce qu'on appelle le risque
modéré ça veut dire quoi le risque
modéré c'est à dire que sur un certain
nombre de territoires on protège les
animaux pour qu'ils soient moins en
contact et moins en risque vis-à-vis de
cette influence a à dire ce qu'il faut
voir c'est qu'aujourd'hui on est déjà
plusieurs pays limitrophes européens qui
sont touchés par mintsa aviaire et donc
on a beau dire des inquiétudes ça veut
dire une énorme vigilance énorme
vigilance ça veut dire aussi que tout ce
dont on est convenus l'année dernière
avec les professionnels pour mieux se
prémunir doit être mise en oeuvre chalus
vraiment la responsabilité des
professionnels et le rôle de l'état qui
l'apprenaient accompagner mais c'est un
sujet qu'on suit avec une extrême
vigilance au jour le jour et justes dans
quatre départements alors c'est très
diffus parce que c'est des basques au
rythme des oiseaux sur les flux
migratoires mais c'est des sujets qu'on
construit quelles que soient les
départements en fait ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose
c'était le signe donné par cck c'est que
le virus d'influenza aviaire est présent
dans les migrations des oiseaux est un
oiseau migrateur il peut arriver
n'importe où à n'importe quel moment et
donc il nous faut avoir une énorme
vigilance et autre question rapidement
ya deux foyers de fièvre catarrhale
ovine qui ont été recensés en corse ont
encore c'est en corse du sud
à dix jours la maladie qui n'avait pas
été recensés en corse depuis 2010 est on
en est aujourd'hui je crois qu'on en a
même trois si ma mémoire est bonne au
moment où je vous parle donc on a des
dispositifs de suivi épidémiologique et
de suivi sanitaire
vis-à-vis de 2,7 ce qu'on appelle la fc
haut et on le suit là aussi de très près
c'est des maladies qui sont différents
de deux lignes flux en deçà aviaire et y
compris dans le traitement par exemple
pour l'afc où il existe un vaccin là où
sur miss flandres ça vire il n'existe
pas encore de vaccin homologué et s'est
essayé vous avez raison de souligner
c'est d'ailleurs un des enjeux qu'on a
en ce moment avec les nouvelles
réglementations pour voir comment on
continuer à rendre accessibles ces
vaccins pour cette fièvre catarrhale
ovine c'est là aussi un sujet évidemment
qu'on suit de près et on merci beaucoup
on avait encore beaucoup de questions
mais malheureusement
[Musique]